hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 ok we're reunited with Ellie and
Carver and we're going our way up this
ladder here so that we can find out the
secrets of the mountain and the key that
we need to find to disable the Machine
and we're all Cubs so let's get back to
the filling it not that kind of
silliness and I'm isolated be okay these
arbitrary methods of isolation are a
little little the well arbitrary a seem
redonkulous but let's keep moving
forward
I wonder what awaits me in the canyon Oh
dad what's this like do I detect a
little thingy
ah scavenger gloat wait yeah did I miss
it or did I get it what else is back
here is there something special
hello what
wait this isn't the right way but what's
back here I'm so curious
just some scraps a-ha logic mad for
scraps aha
I knew I would have trap try your leg
off ammonia [ __ ] give me that
Jeremiah are you not dead there we go
thank you goodbye
jackholes
I don't have another scavenger even
though I've got three bills huh sup
Tommy good I even though I have three
Billie's I didn't quite I don't have
enough now I'm almost out of ammo I've
only got four hundred and seventy three
bullets left okay science division
facility is this where that guy hi
those look like markers popping out of
the ground and what was that
Oh momma are gonna go this way
how damn it's locked hyah boned
why saw some some some now right what da
hell is going on here
yeah these are mark these are totally
these are like either marker replicas or
actual markers jutting out of the ground
here that one's broken off is so weird
okay dramatic music no need to be that
dramatic no need to be overdramatic
you're moving you were moving I saw it
don't cost you don't trust you don't
trust you reclaiming materials that I
have lost in that boss fight that was
totally rigged against me but now
heads up heads up psych Danica's had
time to regroup okay how do we find was
that if she's been dead for 200 years
wait good question dad where's that
you're lying it's perfect that's easy
give me the coordinates well let's hope
danik doesn't find us before we can
build this codex okay so that's pretty
easy when it's called the freakin
Rosetta lab a wonder or hundred oh there
it is boo that could be easy enough for
a child fan hey more engineering
expertise but that's a zebra industries
I think it did huh I'm so glad that even
200 years ago they had the exact same
security flaws that they do in this one
what what the oh there we go got it
nailed it Boop
thank you whoo yeah you better run or
whatever you were running from better
run from me Oh gasps stop at dama you
don't even start it Hey explosion and
then boom new thank you
hi I'm out of I need to reload here just
give me a second
thank you Hey
ah I thought I was gonna be an axe or
something why can I never get anything
why did they run away what
the dude just spontaneously decided that
it was time to burst whoa
whenever I step in that door they they
like bolt out of there ha ha that's so
cool they like sprint away as fast as
they can kind of an interesting mechanic
I do not have a key card but I do have a
suit Kia Legionnaire suit
legionary oh come on I thought that was
gonna be like a legendary all right I'll
stick with the witness suit because I
like it but let us upgrade almost done
on the armors oh-oh I got a bot waiting
for me please have enough tungsten
please please have enough Tong [ __ ] for
me to scavenger BOTS Oh or if I have
enough ooh ah forgot about that man a
lot of stuff how much stuff did I have
let's see if I have enough ration seals
for anything anew I do not all right
gonna let us upgrade to the final armor
upgrade of our suit oops now I will be
nigh on indestructible took almost all
of my semiconductors but oh well was
worth it right maybe
damn you tungsten why are you needed for
everything recharge oh I could do that
could do that easily damn your tungsten
you're the bane of my frickin existence
why do I have so many of the other
materials but none of you make my life
difficult tungsten I don't think I even
get any scrap tungsten this laying about
Knighton's I think that's only from
scavenging damn it do not have the
reprove reott keycards ok moving forward
so I've got an itchy neck today what's
waiting for me okay why is this cushion
doesn't need to be cushioned is this a
padded cell of elevators do I need my
rocket launcher
course what kind of silly question to
that of course I need my rocket launcher
hello anybody home
oh hey it's you guys okay alright I was
worried for a second there okay so I
guess I don't need my record London oh
and this is an assembly station yeah of
course the controls sorry here - a
symbol of codex uh-huh makes sense uh no
according to this we're here to assemble
Rosetta what they cut her into pieces
what oh my god [ __ ] this day I sliced
her up
why haha but some of the piece is
already in the assembly I think it's
another piece over there oh I get it
Rosetta is a Necromorph oh that's why
it's called Rosetta lab oh oh oh okay so
I need to I need to find the rosetta
samples so I guess they're playing off
the rosetta June well there should be a
receptacle that feeds that into laps
cataloging system
okay I'm glad you know what's going on
Ellie
you see if I can feed it in alright here
we go
easy peasy
okay I'll see if I can route that to the
assembly station hold on this is some
weird science
so that explains the beginning opening
scene with all the sliced up parts so
according to the records there are four
more pieces they were checked out of
storage by dr. Serrano right well there
are three buildings in the facility so
if there are more pieces there either in
one all of them all of them yeah all of
us are the doors were locked down from
what I could see yeah well you're in
luck look what I found
Oh curity pop yay give it a shot okay
scuse nah excuse me Carver
excuse me Carver I need it I need it oh
thank you're not even gonna come down
here and hand it to me or you just stay
up in your booth find out what you can
about how assembling Rosetta will create
a codex I'll explore the labs and
recover the rest of the Rosetta slabs
dude duh Isaac Clark don't like this
Isaac Clark does blight resurrecting
dead Necromorph but yeah that that
finally does explain because I was I was
always wondering why in the world that
it was like that why um why the intro
sequence was what it was was what it was
what was anyone gonna jump out at me be
my rocket launcher
I got Rocco
it does looks like there are three
primary buildings in this facility the
one we're in now is biology
there's one for paleontology and one for
geological studies which one should I
check out first just be careful okay why
you think of something out there that
wants to eat me that's not funny I know
Isaac oh haha I know it wasn't a joke
does a car don't make jokes also it
makes more sense that Carver stays
behind to protect Ellie I mean not that
Ellie can't defend herself Ellie's a
badass I'm glad they finally gave her a
gun or at least what I thought was gonna
win I heard her heard shooting going on
before but ripped core in case I wanted
a majestic Ripper screw you I'm going
this way this rickety eerily quiet
looking spiky building oh hi
good time for the rocket launcher Hey
did I get you aa ghost [ __ ] I missed I
got one of your fob where you come from
Oh what of this you son of a [ __ ] you
fall down and I run back out you stunned
imagine I am [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
does beyond [ __ ] that was war yet
beyond recognition come a me bro I will
destroy your family how some [ __ ]
oh god you're so getting rocket launch
hope that hurt [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no you do
not
Oh ciao
good thing I'm so pro and calm in the
face of adversity I handled that so well
damnit I don't have the key card for
that one either Ellie your security pass
failed me I didn't even know where I'm
going I'm not going the correct way that
my indicator says I'm going so I might
be headed towards an optional mission or
something I have no idea really but I
persevere because I care
lots of slabs of various Necromorphs
just laying out here always a good sign
hi Rob oh you don't bird the [ __ ] did
you come from
Oh try a try right run away run away
like little baby I see you you don't
want none of this
get blown I know this is not very ammo
efficient right now but I don't care I
want the satisfying ghoulishly violent
explosions aah Wow where'd you come from
where the [ __ ] [ __ ] did you come from
you somewhere where there's nothing
behind me
hidin that made no sense
the data Isis ah miss this
oh yeah that's where you came from you
came from around that one my buff i
friggin can hit the med kit but I can't
never mind I panic way too much at these
things it's ridiculous
I should be calm and collected I should
be calm and collected hmm
who
okay all right
okay all right I'm testing hello Isaac I
know you're out there calling around yep
you probably think I'm an overzealous
crusader uh-huh mindlessly following the
whim of an angry god it's an easy
conclusion to draw I don't fault you for
it goodness you may be surprised to know
that I'm a man of science
you'll understand that I'm right know
about every oh I'll completely agree Oh
couldn't agree more coach ah and let's
change this rocket launcher around cos
not helping me at all
and he's like directed suspension field
what about wasn't there like ah that's
what I was looking for that's what I
wanted yes that that is what I want I
want the detonator I love the detonator
and I still can't make any of these
because they all require tungsten my
goodness okay anyway but that that is
what I wanted that is what I need oh man
okay so I need I definitely need more
clip ones on this to flip rate of fire
I'm not doing it for fast firing but yes
I don't know I don't know I don't know
tungsten again God what's the tungsten
you need to calm your tits on the
tungsten cuz finally now I can
strategically place detonator mines
which I like a lot I like I like that
that is the thing that I like to do
so like if I okay hang on let me get
this what is you are you good to reload
one rate of fire I guess I should have
used that but now I'll put it in later I
have no time
Oh another tungsten do I have one yes
God thank you I actually have one I
don't care if you don't have to spam the
button I enjoy it a secret killing
murderers in here I also need some ammo
which I'm going to have to get soon heck
I might even have to craft some holy
hell hot death yeah I want the hot death
gun too bad I can't make anything
because I don't have the range or toys I
will have plenty of resources when I
play the skin on my own which I'm
looking very much forward to technically
I could play it again on my own
simultaneously but I will not I have so
much scrap metal I don't need to even
worry about wasting it and I need med
packs good thing I sell at some attic
gel yeah I'm back up to full power Isaac
Clarke is greatest bounty bounty hunter
you're not a bounty hunter at all
greatest Monster Hunter whoa do you
engineer either Clarke is the greatest
engineer I am in a fricken optional
mission
those are satisfyingly dead I am in an
optional mission okay
these seem vicious wonder what they're
for
what kind of defense mechanism is this
weird oh no I didn't need to come here
okay
who's out there who wants some hey
you're not gonna get your way through
the aah whoa what the what no there you
are Jesus
good thing I'm destroyed those bodies
over there oh yeah ugly son of a [ __ ]
hey scavenge II I've never ever seen you
get to work okay I got to be careful
with this I probably can't just throw it
that would probably be a bad idea
yep you die
you die like super hardcore death like
with guitars and rock stars
seriously what is the point of these
lasers the scene was highly irregular
all right Sunday's burn
push I've got a piece of roseto I'm
sitting away yeah which which piece is
it card itself the cross-section but it
doesn't look like anything I recognize
okay I'll get it print right arriv
okey-dokey sounds good I don't know what
that optional mission that popped up was
but I know you don't you wanna push what
about the marker huh you were saying
something you just you've got cut up I
think I will Hey
I was sure but Janek Isaac Clark don't
surrender for nobody Isaac Clark does
what Isaac Clark wants and I think lark
wants to kill a human a human enemies
are much better than Necromorph enemies
I can handle human enemies human enemies
are freaking easy by comparison alright
I think I'm done here
I think yes yeah I'm done here no other
doors here correct
good good good does it clear happy now
we know this is even gonna work do you
find out how they make a codex from all
this yeah it looks like they use magnet
ohmic forensic neurology which produces
a data stream stored in the codex hmm
they lifted the codes machine right hand
for brain okay that sounds familiar at
least a poker
I'll be there soon haha get it cuz Ellie
your I got poked up haha I'm fine right
oh oh no that's right
I know it's cuz little probe in the
brain buzzers shut up everybody can do I
have the code for here yet
oh this is the disposal services oh well
yes go in I haven't done an optional
mission in a while of take a look I
thought I was gonna do one a while back
but apparently that fell through I have
no idea
also I got my Girl Scout cookies in
today Oh mmm I know I brought him to be
eating and playing at the same time but
they're sitting right here and I can't
ignore them alright I'm better now
doesn't everyone get like that when they
get Thin Mints from
oh this is wait a minute this is what
Wow okay now I'm confused here am I
supposed to take that shuttle to
different places you don't I'm gonna
save all the optional missions for me
later if you want to play you got a play
for your shelf who bad I'm - mission
you're mine just like these Thin Mints
Ramon I'm
okay I'm not gonna continue to eat on
camera that's unprofessional if there's
anything that anyone knows about
markiplier that I professional who baked
Rican stab your creakin with a buzzer
what's that sound good job there way to
be a real winner
gratulations on moving yourself with a
gene pool I guess
scavenge his dead body for me Billy
thank you return Wendy valuables say you
find what did I get full zoom scope hi
no you do not know you do not know you
do not ha ha ha gotcha
yeah go give me you this one mine one
body this guy was talking about burn hey
can't get me I'm too pro as I have
stated many times before I'm a
professional gamer of sorts I am
expertise miss in all things related to
shooting and talking this so was I not
even supposed to come this way in the
beginning I hit caps locks again because
apparently that was probably the lack
the original marker the black marker
found on earth predates the rises man
card yeah yes I am fact the marker
exerts a field of influence that guides
and grows biological organisms evolving
them over time towards some greater
lover you see what this is good no oh
not you things I remember you if I'm
careful I can catch you ha
all right good I'll just let you blow
yourself up wait hang on I need to throw
something else right okay looks like the
actual I haven't seen this infection of
okay come on and come at me come at me
la bouche or I could just use my frickin
grenade launcher well that didn't work
as I had intended it to ha damn it how
do I get that off I forget how to do
that I forget how did damn it how do I
remove that from the wall there was a
way maybe there isn't a way anymore
well that poses a problem for me I guess
this duffle bag will work okay
I'm making my way very slowly through
here I need to hurry the Frick up
there's nasty groves and everywhere in
here it's mocking some of the doorways
is it organic it says here there's a
sterilization in case the containment
breach Jim I'll check it out
oh I can finally shoot you guys I didn't
think I could shoot you before dammit
that one explosion took away like a
bajillion of my health a whole gajillion
gas pump offline I just got to do
everything around here it's all me let's
read the text log in the event of
containment failure simulation guys
Mosby administer from the earth
civilization booth these airtight
chambers will protect you from the
highly corrosive sterilization gas all
are protected biological things you in
the infected area will be disintegrated
it is important that the terrorizing
guys make six days to be maintained in
old times you're taking the safety of
those around you depend on it door I
Spit there we go okay I'm tired after
reading that Oh No I'll be back I'll be
back
no I don't know why they changed these
things from actually being babies damn
censorship
I'm not saying like I'm pro maybe
shooting or anything like that but I
mean it was an artistic choice and I
mean alright never mind I have nothing
in defense of shooting babies that is
not what I'm saying I'm not saying that
at all
no one misquote me no no anything like
that okay
no thank you add too much just enough
yeah Oh Bess ah it's that voice I love
that voice hi
you're [ __ ] you know that's what us do
stop that right now thank you
alright so we're good to go
not much maintaining they needed to be
done there sounds like someone did
sabotage that hmm interesting
looks like about about an inside job I
suspect uh it appears that we are almost
out of time in fact we are all out of
time let me just get this
reload clip yeah so anyway we are all
out of time so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
not your door
there's no bomb
Klaus
Oh No